do you consider yourself
a capitalist would you say you're a
capitalist you believe in capitalism
i believe in uh fair capitalism
do you believe in socialism i also
believe in democratic socialism
so what do you think is too much taxes
to so
so i ask the question more with numbers
so you're a data person and
and i've looked at this a lot i'm
curious to know what you're going to say
let's take a side capitalism and let's
take us out socialism let's not give it
any
labels let me ask this question i make
a hundred thousand dollars a year how
much
money is too much for me to pay the
government in taxes
what should what should the ban be i i
think that depends on where you live
making that money
um for one thing so your hundred
thousand dollars in new york versus your
hundred thousand dollars um
in federal taxes just look at it from a
federal tax standpoint
don't don't break it down with state so
state california thirteen three
uh if i'm in tennessee zero if i'm in
texas zero florida zero
just assume federal i make a hundred
thousand dollars a year
how much is too much taxes for me to
hand over to the government for the hard
work that i put in how much is too much
of that full hundred um again it depends
what you get back for given what we get
back for it
um here um i think the 33 40 percent
level is
is fair okay but so
thousand dollars that's on a hundred
thousand dollars so so that's on a
hundred thousand okay how about a
million dollars
i think i i think on a million dollars i
i think there could be i
i agree with a sort of proportional um
tax
percentage on that um so
if i say 33 and a third or 40 percent is
a max for
a hundred thousand dollars um i could
see that as like the first hundred
thousand dollars
um and then sort of a gradient in a
slightly lower
direction get up to the million but
that's still taxing
you know that is a proportional amount
so uh up to a hundred thousand dollars
33 and a half percent okay
up to quarter million dollars let's just
say you're saying 40
if i'm making million up uh what should
be my taxes a million up
well again i think you just do that same
40 or what whatever whatever the grid is
okay fair enough got it so then 33 and a
half all the way up to 40.
right fair okay so
okay so then the states the state you're
in the state i used to be in
you're in california i'm in texas now
your state is 13-3
do you think that's too much to be
living in a state of california
um well there are certainly taxes in
california
um i i i do pay them a lot of them
um but i also think um
one of the things california does um
which
other states don't do quite as much as
it sort of does referendum out the
things that people
have to spend their taxes the things
that um
are are voting and people can vote on to
basically decide where their taxes go
yeah this referendum is on the ballot
right it's kind of the equivalent
of so it's like if i'm getting stuff for
my marginal proportion or additional
proportion
of taxes um i think that's
and a state does that well or nation
does that well if you sort of move out
of california
i think that's a good thing um and so
at a certain level of of earning um it's
not as necessary
but for sort of individuals on the
ground where you know there's there's
health concerns there's education
concerns there's there's
you know safety concerns all of that i
think money needs to come into
the system to be able to sort of make it
um run
is taking that to a whole different
level and they're losing a lot of people
especially the younger hungry people not
the people that already made their money
because
there's a different story between your
money making years
versus you deciding you'd make your
money to a place for instance i was in
monaco for a 10 year anniversary my wife
and i we went there
and you know they they're the popular
the city is smaller than central park
right
and the life expectancy in monaco is the
highest in the world people live 89
years yeah this is after they made their
hundred million dollars and they
moved to monaco that's different you
don't see a 22 year old saying i'm going
to go make my money in monaco
right they're going to go to a different
place as a money making
years of your life 25 to whatever the
number
is going to be 55 let's just say where
you're willing to play offense and go
out there and work the 12 16 hour days
do you think it's fair the kind of taxes
a state like california is passing down
to its people
um again i i think for the people just
starting out
and the people making less um that
i would equate you know sort of lower
that tax relative to people making more
people you're talking about who have
more um
who um who have more to be taxed
um than someone just coming in i mean i
started out in new york city
um where like my entire paycheck went
yeah i mean obviously i started out
chase as an analyst i mean my paycheck
basically went to taxes and my rent and
that was that was like it
um so so so i do think that it does
matter like you say you know whether
you're coming in
early um and you're in your life in your
career in your money-making situation or
if you're
someone who works on tips or if you're
someone who works multiple jobs if
you're someone who works gig jobs
um that that i do think um it's it's
better to have a lower tax rate for for
those people to get them into the
economy and to help them build that sort
of stability
relative to people who who have made
more or
have more that's what i've talked about
in terms of a proportional
uh sort of tax thing because because
that that makes them stay
um and it also brings a foundational
kind of economic stability to those
those people and therefore
ultimately it goes forward into the
revenues of
a state of a city like l.a
if you have the people at the bottom
you know able to move
well i mean i you know uh it's it's
interesting you say that and i agree
with that when i lived in l.a
and i would go down that 405 every day i
would sit i'm like okay let me get this
here what the hell am i doing
spending two hours a day on the freaking
405 freeway i landed one night one day
at 3 30.
i wanted to go from lax to rafi's place
to eat it's 18 miles it took two and a
half hours to go there i would not
what am i doing to go two and a half
hours
and 18 20 miles to go to a restaurant so
and
i moved to texas and i had a guy sitting
next to me who was a socialist he's not
a capitalist
and we were driving and he says man i
don't like the fact that we have to pay
the toll here in texas
i said well the way texas works is you
don't pay state taxes
if you don't want to use the toll then
don't use it take the streets you don't
have to pay the tax
but in texas you pay taxes for things
you use
in california you pay for things you'll
never use like they had an express road
here in texas dallas and i would
pay the money to go through this express
but there's only two cars and i'm like
i'll pay this no problem
i'm able to go past 300 cars i never saw
that in california so when you're
talking about
and by the way this is a man that left
california at 37 years old prime money
making yours and i'm going to be making
money for another 20 30 years
and that could they could have gotten a
lot of those taxes but they they abused
it and i'm seeing a massive exodus with
a lot of younger other people that
relate to what i'm saying
so going back to you said you you're
you're believing fair capitalism i think
that's the word used i don't want to put
words in your mouth i think you said
fair capitalism and you believe in
democratic socialism
socialist socialism which is an element
of what bernie talks about
but bernie also talks about 70 and you
were supportive of bernie i think you
guys did some work together he relied on
some of the economic stuff
what are your thoughts when we're
talking about 70 of taxes and just
bashing rich people the top one percent
of america they're just so this and
they're doing this and they're doing
oh my gosh you feel guilty to talk about
the fact that you make some money it
used to be a time people
admired successful people i mean you're
somebody that's made millions of dollars
you're somebody that's very successful
you're somebody that
essentially is top one percent if you
worked at goldman sachs as a
top person you are one percent what's
wrong with going to the one person and
here's the thing i don't want to be in a
bernie bash moment because i i truly
believe a bernie against the trump
stood a better chance than a biting
against the trump because at least you
know what bernie stands and that's one
of the things i respect about bernie
bernie's bernie you don't know where
biden's at when i looked at bernie i'm
like you know what
it doesn't matter if i disagree with
this garden i respect the guy that has
his own ways of fixing things and he
doesn't flip-flop and i would have loved
to see
those two guys going at it but
unfortunately i don't think we're ever
going to see that although it would have
been incredible debates
people would have tuned into so going
back to it
i watch you i've watched your videos and
i've watched your interview with bernie
that you guys did i think in 2013 or
2016. i don't know what it was it was
many 2009. i watched that as well i
watched a lot of your work
you seem very reasonable you seem fair
you seem like you're able to stay in the
middle and kind of uh hear both sides of
the argument out
how does someone like you as reasonable
you are get behind seventy percent for
rich people
so um the work i did with bernie was
mostly on the fed and
and and the idea of um and on wall
street so the idea of basically creating
going back to fairness um you know sort
of an auditing path a transparency path
seeing what the fed was doing where it
went who's getting the most benefit
um and this ties in and also from the
standpoint of wall street banks
um to what extent were they basically
creating securities and
um you know that was hiding or the risk
that ultimately
uh we had all seen in the economy and
the financial system which i believe
still exists um it's been papered over
the fed's thrown money at it so it's
deeper in the system but but it's there
and i think that yeah so that's what i'm
talking about when i talk about a fair
um environment from the standpoint of 70
percent
for um a fall of rich
people um you know if you take someone
and you know wherever you you
calibrate that number and you say 70 of
all of your income
um is is gone um i i do that from an
income from standpoint not a wealthier
standpoint i think that's that's very
high
from a gradient which is which is where
i i i would disagree with an absolute
level
like that um what what i'm saying is
that there
should be some sort of a gradient um
between
someone more wealthy paying more of the
initial part of their income
relative to you know sort of a number
that that that is that high so it
becomes proportional
you're not paying 70 i don't believe um
it's necessary to pay 70
of your income but i'll say this too i
think companies
should pay more in taxes to avoid some
of these situations in terms of getting
money into
the budget of our country into reducing
the deficit of our country which of
course now has grown because of the
virus and
it does grow because of different crises
um i i think that
rather than not paying taxes into the
revenue of the treasury department
which right now companies pay about 10
to 13 of the full
amount of revenue that goes into the
into our coffers as a nation
um it used to be much higher than that
there's maybe a happy medium
but because they're not paying as much
just mathematically
there's a greater amount to be covered
in order to run the country and if
in order to run the country and it's not
coming from
growth um which i think would be the
better way to do it and talk about
economic growth
earlier than having a proportional tax
system
allows some of that um to be
retrieved not not not all of it not
making up for for companies not putting
as much in
and not necessarily going to that
absolute level for
everyone who is wealthy in terms of
their income
um but i do think there's there's
there's there's a give and take there
i think that's a high number i i don't i
don't um
but but i also think that we have to as
a nation use that money whatever it is
um for things that actually sustain
economic growth
and companies and individuals and rich
people could be doing that it's not to
say that that's not happening
but but to the extent that taxes are
taken out they should give benefit
to the overall country and the overall
growth of our country and i think that
helps both the people
at the bottom as well as
those who are wealthier because you just
you just have better roads like it
doesn't take it might take you two and a
half hours to go anywhere
once coronavirus is over out of la to
anywhere else that could still happen
but but the idea is that you have a more
efficient system whether it's
technological or infrastructure-wise
because
money's going into things that everyone
dreams
not just rich not just poor but all of
us
and you think governments are being
efficient right now with work
with our taxes no no no no so why would
why would taxpayers
why would taxpayers feel confident
constantly paying more taxes
while the government can go out there
and print money and quantitative easing
give it to
whoever they want and i'm sitting here
working my ass off
making 80 grand a year 100 to whoever it
is 150 000
a year i'm barely seeing my kids and i'm
seeing them being bailed out but i have
to pay
50 of my taxes to you and i'm not seeing
the roads getting better
i'm not seeing streets getting better i
i have a very hard time with that
exactly the point
that's exactly the point the the fact is
we shouldn't pay taxes into this massive
quantitative easing
money creation into just sort of a
market perspective rather than building
the roads or
or or having faster trains or whatever
it might be or having better hospitals
or more or more efficient
you know testing system now or whatever
it might be um yeah i absolutely i i
totally agree with that we we have
mismanaged
the the creation of money let alone our
taxes
because of well because we mismanaged
both
effectively um but but throwing the qe
into it throwing the federal reserve's
balance sheet into it throwing that
massive inflation of of
just the availability of cheap money
that doesn't go into doing anything
i mean you know i don't even have i
don't even see lines on the 101 when i
get out of la and they're they're not
they don't paint them they're old you
can't you just make up your own lanes
that's the point though why why are they
paying 13.3 and here's the thing though
because
look i was telling you earlier i lived
there 24 years
and we're looking at four other places
to go live and we were looking to go
back to
you know somewhere around what is that
the
place right by goro hills it's right
outside of agora hills
it's a nice area we're looking at there
we're looking at malibu we're looking at
uh
newport right we want to go back to la
i'm like my friends are there everything
i know is la 24 years from 12 years old
to 37 i'm la minus me being in the
military
we looked at greenwich we looked at
florida we looked at uh uh
texas california went from first place
to last place
in no time because they keep saying pay
more taxes
gas tax this tax and california
okay how many more things you're going
to keep raising and nothing is getting
better so
a question for you who are you
comfortable
having more power people government
or companies in order if you were to say
one two three what would you say
i would say people companies and
government
we're on the same page okay
you